after winning Game three with the black
pieces magnus carlsen the reigning world
champion took control of the 2016 World
Chess Championship match he moved into
Game four of the tiebreaks
with the white pieces putting Sergey
Karjakin on tilt and when you go on tilt
as they say you play the Sicilian and
that's exactly what Sergey Karjakin did
it explains why I play the Sicilian
every time I played the black pieces
because I live my life on tilt
now after d4 and the open Sicilian is
reached we knew we were in for a sharp
game where either Sergey Karjakin was
going to win and even the score or
likely go down in flames trying and
after night after f3 a tricky little
move order perhaps avoiding any mainline
ideas surgery cardiac and might have had
up his sleeve
he really forced Sergei to mix it up
early and Sergei jumped in without with
his eyes closed and you know
skinny-dipped on the way down took off
everything and said here we go after 'if
I've really the main line we can get
here one of the more strategical ways to
punish a 5 is with the move Bishop to b5
check one of the principle ideas to the
Sicilian is that normally black should
not try for a move like a 5 until the b5
Square has been guarded to give you an
example of that in the main line Knight
orphe one of the things that that really
defines the position after Knight to c3
is that black must play a6 before
expanding into the aggressive variations
of the e5 Knight or if again after
Bishop e3 e5 is a move after f3 which
would be very similar to the game a 5 s
a move and in all of these positions
white is forced to release to move the
pony out of his his central post and
black then gets compensation for the
potentially weak d6 pawn the weak d5
square because black is gaining a little
bit of the initiative in terms of
development and and this all works
because white doesn't have the move
Bishop to b5 check as an example after
Knight to c3 if black is to play e5
immediately this move comes in black is
immediately being set to deal with the
white
and without the without the LightSquared
bishop these Knights are going to
dominate d5 and f5 from now until
Kingdom Come and black is going to be
positionally worse now why didn't
Carlson play Bishop to b5 then in this
game after f3 e5 well the first answer
is it's not as simple in these
variations because White has chosen to
play f3 rather than the more natural
developing move Knight to c3 Bishop to
b5 check can actually be met by Bishop
d7 here and in some of these positions
after the trade White has to deal with
the fact that black can now get d5
immediately d5 will now equalized in the
center thus eliminating all of black's
positional problems of the d6 pawn to d5
square and again it's something that is
normally not possible if you simply
change out f3 for the knight being on c3
then you see that a move like d5 is just
is just neither here nor there because
white will just capture the pawn and win
win the game on the spot so this is a
little bit of a basic description of the
first stage of the game but as you know
I like to do establish a and every move
explain kind of approach in my videos so
that as we get to the complex stuff you
really do feel like you have a good
grasp of what's going on so in summary
why is black able to break this normal
positional dogma in a Sicilian which is
that you cannot play e5 before you stop
Bishop b5 check he can do so because
Carlsen first varied with a side line
with the move f3 and there is no knight
on c3 preventing the d5 positional
strike that equalizes so there you go
and that means that after E 5 it's time
for Carlsen to just retreat which he was
ok with because after Bishop to e7 he
sees the opportunity of this move order
to go for yet another structure that if
it's not just a guaranteed draw it is a
guaranteed very difficult time for your
opponent and that of course is the
Marauder bind structure as we all know
the Meraki bind is c4 and E 4 vs either
the pawns on e 7 and end this Bishop
being kettle's like a dragon maroc see
sometimes the pawn is on e6 and then we
have like a hedgehog mirach see where
black
play for b6 and Bishop e7 those
positions can occur in Queens Indians in
different one Knight f3 ready systems so
there are different ways for black to
play them against the Meraki and it's
not to say that any of those scenarios
black is just losing but it is always a
very tough and slow game for black it
takes a very long time and it takes a
lot of very accurate discipline to play
to be able to play the black side
against Amarok see when your opponent
just has more space they have two pawns
in the center that you do not they have
complete control over the certain color
complex like we saw Carlsen do in the
game 3 where he got a complete control
over the darks for a complex and
eventually won that game as black here
is just it's very difficult and if black
cannot organize the the strikes of
either b5 to undermine this d5 to
undermine it or get a lot of pressure
against the c-4 pawn with moves like
Bishop e6 knight c6 to a5 the rook comes
to c8 it black means a lot of time to
really fight for equality in these
merace bind centers and so the tone is
really being set early in this game by
Magnus Carlsen that he is going to make
blacks like difficult if he ever expects
to mix it up because black has to win
this game in order to tie it if Magnus
even gets a draw he retains his title as
the world chess champion so 85 has
played Corey Aachen is just all in at
this point he's going to play the
aggressive variations of the black side
of the maroc see one of the main ideas
behind this early a pawn advances what
you see here there are many positions in
the maroc see where this Queen lands on
a5 and you put a rook on c8 after the
bishop comes to e6 and you look for
pressure but whenever the pawn is on a 7
you have tactical issues sometimes it's
that the Queen is undefended
because the rook isn't guarding her and
so once the white queen comes to d2
there's discovered attacks sometimes
it's just that even if you get the
pressure on the C file you don't have
anywhere to go beyond that because again
you don't have enough space to compete
with white on the Queen side the
disadvantage for cardiac and even though
he just gained those two advantages I
described the Queen is defended he has
more space is that he just wasted two
moves with the pull on rather than moves
to get the other pieces developed and so
Carlsen just takes it very simple I'm
going to consolidate put every piece on
their most natural square and here
rook to b1 which is exactly the way you
play a textbook maroc see we have
threats of b4 and even if you want
poisson then we'll just renew the threat
of b4 and we are going to slowly start
to push your pieces back from the first
player's perspective in this in this
type of maroc scene and i really don't
know how else to describe it because
besides that's exactly what happened
here this is the kind of position that
black is normally if black is in a game
where draw is okay which by the way most
the time when these top grandmasters
play is exactly the kind of game that
black is in right let's be honest
hashtag onigiri just kidding Gary we all
know everyone loves to draw nobody in
black and seriously if black is normally
in a position where equality is not the
end of the world and he can just sit
tight one of the advantages to the
structure for black is that for all of
its lack of space for all the control
white has that I described black has no
long-term positional weaknesses and so
you can play the black side of these
positions if you have a very patient
mindset and in some cases you're willing
for the half-point result but for this
structure to be reached in a must-win
situation for Chris Sergey Carioca and
the Challenger you knew the Russian was
in for a big big time struggle in this
game and Carlson just comes forward
naturally doesn't even get
over-aggressive with b4 he allows some
some some trades to be made or offers
trades which if what if black doesn't do
it then you can guess where this night
is going that's right
going to be for where it's going to help
its buddy gain even more control over d5
in the next and the next several moves
we see the writing kind of starts to
fall on the wall Bishop to c6 the brook
comes to d1 h5 is played kind of a
desperate attempt to create counter play
on the Kings side where you really don't
have a lot of business attacking Carlsen
just continues to sit tight
this is a very strong and common
maneuver if you're looking for patterns
what patterns can we take from games and
apply to our own games if you are not
asking yourself that and every time you
are reviewing a top grandmaster game you
are doing yourself a disservice what
patterns from this game can I take and
apply to my own games whether it's an
opening pattern the the best moves in
the openings being revealed to me by the
strong players a pawn structure idea or
a very common Rema nuvaring of the
pieces this is exactly something that
white loves to get at
a battery facing the Queen site in these
Roxy blinds because once that bishop
comes to b6 it just puts black even more
on his toes and after Knight to d7 to
guard Bishop b6 that just means the d5
square is going to be more available
here any moment and okay so first first
white deals with the threats on the a
file which putting a knight on d5 was
also possible a lot of those positions
but Carlsen is still playing B I'm going
to make sure you really don't have
anywhere else to go right I'm going to
send you back to the van down by the
river where there is no place else to go
play a little tickle here eventually I'm
going to execute something on that d5
square b6 has played not a bad move
because it strengthens the c5 square but
also creates a pawn target so black
isn't a little bit of a bind there here
comes the D file being doubled and now
Carlsen really just shows that he was in
control of this game when he just takes
h4 he's not going to sit tight forever
if the position is just going to be held
by black and whites going to have all
the options here and lots of space he
figures you might as well go grab a pawn
to trading f4 is not a bad idea because
that opens up a new square which is the
d4 square at some point to be useful and
once he follows the the elimination of
this Knight with one Bishop he figures
there's no reason to hold on to the
bishop pair in general makes another
trade just so we can come back to
executing tactics against this d5 square
as we said it was going to happen
although and then were the move order
that was played it didn't need to happen
because Carlson was able to execute a
media tactics with the move Knight to d5
he's either just going to win the d6
pawn outright or he's going to give he's
going to give Corey Aachen the
opportunity to go for something even
more crazy which is to sacrifice the
exchange Corey Aachen is on tilt here I
mean again a lot of moves here are doing
good for white but if he just sits on
the position Carlsen would have the
pleasant choice of just sitting on it
himself moves like just continuing to
dominate the light squares and leave
black with with not a lot of choices or
considered just going and gobbling up
the d6 pawn because after that Falls
likely to be six pawn Falls to any of
those would have been playable but Corey
Aachen decided well might as well
brisket if I'm ever going to taste that
biscuit or at least smell it in the oven
Carlson's house and I'm going to go sack
the exchange that's what he did here but
the rest as they say was a matter of
technique you can't really blame the
Russian for getting in this completely
lost position given the given the match
scenario he was facing but still the
Sicilian just didn't come I get the kind
of Sicilian you want it didn't get a lot
of tension to be honest if I was to
provide one last piece of sort of
opening preparation feedback for karaoke
and I'm not really the kind of player
who can give them criticism I would say
that I don't think the e5 approach is
even against a six it's not the most
flexible way to play a position where
you can where you can maybe try to get
some tactics later on usually that you
know the main line Knight orphe with the
e6 variations things that allow for the
position to change and take a different
nature and under a lot of different
circumstances that would have been my
choice if I was in a must a must-win
scenario where I have to play I have to
play for something that's dynamic and
tricky I don't feel like allowing this
closed structure the very fixed mirach
see blind position where White's going
to own the light squares is really ever
the ideal way to play a must-win
situation as black but is there ever
really an ideal way to play a must-win
situation as black against the most
accurate chess player of all time in
Magnus Carlsen probably not so again
that's why I said it's feedback not
criticism but here we go the exchange is
won and after after that falls white
continues to own the light squares and
black just runs out of time we get we
get more more opportunities for black
created if he can get the Queen in here
and maybe get the Brooke involved
because the white King is a little open
the problem is in order to get into a
scenario like that you're probably
risking even more than you're going
after and after rook a to Czech Queen up
to along with my foreshadowing comment
that you're probably risking more than
you're going after I'm going to give you
a chance to find what may have been one
of the the sexiest ways to ever end a
World Chess Championship in history if
you ask me of course those of you who
are just looking at the engine above me
have already seen it but I'm not going
to go with Bishop f8 I'm going to go
with what car Aachen did and show you
the nicest move to finish the game the
Karlsson played which was Queen
and the Challenger immediately resigned
if King takes h6 we have check Alina
lush Lamba and if G takes age six we
sing la la la Bamba and just like that
the World Chess Championship was one
which puts us in a position to do a
quick recap of what happened in the
tiebreak we saw both of the first two
games drawn probably Game two was
already a sign of things to come but
psychologically despite facing the black
pieces Magnus Carlsen was not going to
to let that deter him from being
aggressive he won what I believe was the
game of the match that's the third game
video if you haven't watched my analysis
to Game three and the epic attack that
he launched in a very Kings Indian style
you have to go back and watch that video
game three so probably that was really
the defining moment of the match him
winning that game is black Game four was
the game you just saw here not really
the ideal scenario for the Challenger to
have a must-win game as black but hey
that's what she wrote that's the
storyline and with it we have a world
champion once again magnus carlsen
defends his title for the third time
against the second a second different
opponent the first two matches coming
against Vichy and not as we know and we
say I do I do you we wish you well we
thank you for following all of our
coverage on chess comm we give a
congratulations to all of the chef's
websites and companies that invested so
much time and resources into covering
this match from the official broadcast
team the wonderful job that you do po
guard did the organizational efforts by
Aegon and fee day I think they impress
some people with with the way that it
came together despite the horrible bug
bugs on their board so I believe they
deserve a congratulations chefs 24
deserves a huge congratulations their
website had so many viewers during the
live shell that it crashed just
phenomenal work by everybody providing
commentary over at just 24 just
top-notch stuff everybody else I mean
chess pays had coverage chess bomb every
website that puts in so much time and
effort to put in resources to covering
these sort of flagship events for the
chef Scott for the chess community it
just deserves a huge thumbs up and so I
congratulate all of them I congratulate
Magnus Carlsen and I hope that everybody
enjoyed chess coms cover
no live coverage but providing as many
video breakdowns educational tips and
highlights which is really our kind of
format the bread-and-butter and the way
we like to deliver content anyway I hope
you enjoyed it hope you have fun please
subscribe to our channel share these
videos and look for more from us coming
up in the very near future as chefs calm
rolls out even more of its own events
and its own Big Time Championship so
peace out everybody thanks for watching
thanks for tuning in and had fun
covering the 2016 World Chess
Championship